[Music]
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day don't teach a man to fish and you
feed yourself he's a grown man
fishings not that hard
I once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name best friend I
ever had
[Music]
crying acceptable at funerals and the
grand can when people get too chummy
with me I like to call them by the wrong
name to let them know I don't really
care about
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have wait wait I worried what you just
heard was give me a lot of bacon and
eggs what I said was give me all the
bacon and eggs you have do you
understand birthdays were invented by
Hallmark to sell cards fish for sport
only not for meat fish meat is
practically a vegetable any dog under
fifty pounds is a cat and cats are
pointless I also think it's pointless
for a human to paint scenes of nature
when they could just go outside and
stand in it put some alcohol in your
mouth to block the words from coming out
you had me at meat tornado
normally if given a choice between doing
something and nothing I choose to do
nothing but I will do something if it
helps someone else stick with it I'd
work all night if it meant nothing got
done
there has never been a sadness that
can't be cured by breakfast food
fishing relaxes made it's like yoga
except I still get to kill something I'm
a simple man I like pretty dark-haired
women and breakfast food
on my deathbed my final wish is to have
my ex-wives rushed to my side so I can
use my dying breath to tell them both to
go to hell one last time it's never too
early to learn that the government is a
greedy piglet that suckles on a
taxpayer's teat until they have sore
chapped nipples there are only three
ways to motivate people money fear and
hunger
[Music]
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts be ice cream or be nothing zero
stars
when I eat it is the food that is scared
are you gonna tell a man that he can't
fart in his own car
I like saying no it lowers their
enthusiasm
it's always a good idea to demonstrate
to your co-workers that you are capable
of withstanding a tremendous amount of
pain
clear alcohols are for rich women on
diets there's only one thing I hate more
than lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk
never have asked two things whole last
one thing
[Music]
hey guys you know what static air slowly
for more Latino content right here